Phase one is the pre data, or menu data. This is the first set of screens the
user sees and needed to be loaded immediately. In GRITS, all of our menu assets
are defined and positioned in HTML. So the browser will handle loading of these
assets as part of parsing and processing the HTML file for presentation. Since
these assets are defined in a DOM, their loading is handled by the browser's
page parser and handler. So, we don't have to do anything explicit here. Once
the user hits Join Game, we enter into a new phase. We must load all the
scripting data that's used by the game. The data hasn't been defined by the
DOM. As such, we need to issue commands to our asset loader to fetch that
information and wait until it's been loaded. It's worth pointing out that the
game scripting and menu scripting are really two separate code bases. Which is
why we load the separately, as well. The scripting code will load up the object
definitions, systems, physics, et cetera, and all of the other things we need
to run the game. But not needed during menu browsing. So here is a list of
scripts that we use inside of GRITS. What we'd like you to do is pass the array
of file names, to the asset manager as a batch operation to load all of the
data. After the batch is entirely loaded call window.alert to notify the player
that the files are loaded